let's go next to our caller from the
6:02 area code who's calling today from
602 uh blow it to me yes it is
laughing oh boy this is James from
Phoenix let me know if you can hear me
yes I can you know James the weirdest
thing is going on in between ice when I
write and when you spoke I could have
sworn I heard a woman's voice it's
almost like there are lines crossed
that's weird yeah cuz I'm totally alone
in this room right now as it should be
I there's no woman anyway anyway my
having this dropped out do you think
that the prevention movement has sort of
missed its moment in the United States
of having a big limelight or do you
think we're gonna have to not wait
another 30 40 years for another Bernie
Sanders to build up and kind of have a
huge record behind and listen here's the
reality we go I'm not worried about that
I don't think that's going to be the
case remember Bernie Sanders moved into
the forefront a lot of ideas that are
now arguably mainstream or mainstream
for a large majority of the United
States and that's absolutely fantastic
but he we we have not yet gotten to
turning that slate of ideas into
accomplishments is it going to happen
under a Joe Biden presidency no it's not
but could some elements maybe be made a
reality I am hopeful and that's where it
comes down to you know if we want the
next four years to be as progressive as
possible now that Bernie's out and it's
Biden versus Trump the best shot we have
is to have a stake in the Biden
presidency by all getting the hell out
in voting and pressuring Biden and the
House and the Senate
if Biden is lucky enough to become
president of the United States to do as
much as possible of a truly progressive
agenda and I know that it's
underwhelming that it's ready
but if we don't do that then it's just
Trump another four years and we go in
the completely wrong direction you
understand what I'm saying my friend
yeah yeah yeah under very listening I
don't know do you think Joe Biden would
even listen because I get what you're
saying
I just don't think Joe Biden would
listen as if I can do anything to change
it as one man I think that he would
listen if the right people are talking
to him we've seen him make some
modification begin to some of his
financial policy based on Elizabeth
Warren's ideas I would hope now that
Bernie is out that maybe Joe Biden is
going to listen to Bernie and adopt
something from Bernie's platform I'm
hopeful and you know what it might not
happen but it's definitely not happening
under Donald Trump that's for sure all
right nice I couldn't hear most of you
but I'll see you on the show later
keep up the good work David listen all
the way from Phoenix all right very good
all right I'm gonna take a quick break
I'm gonna reset the phone system if
you're holding don't hang up if the
system hangs up on you please call back
we're gonna see I think the tubes are
very full right now so we're gonna go to
a quick break
don't hang up but if I accidentally
knock you off line please call right
back